why are children allowed at weddings
first of all
no children wedding every time
i see a wedding invite and you haven't
seen little guy in a suit
he's cute as [ __ ] if i see a wedding
invite and it doesn't say
no children please i don't want to go
we keep putting little band-aids and
[ __ ] covering our eyes with petroleum
jelly we're like no i don't see that kid
being bad no it's fine
no that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] kid he sucks
don't [ __ ] bring him next time yeah
figure your kid out discipline him do
something he sucks he does suck being a
parent is probably one of the worst
[ __ ] things because there's no right
answer yeah there's no right answer and
there's no like guidebook no at all it's
an it's everyone has their opinion it's
just like running a country right like
we all have our own opinions on how to
run this country there's probably good
things that could happen from these
opinions and good things that but then
we're somewhere in the middle and
there's still gonna be [ __ ] [ __ ] up
like there's no possible way to do it
right
[Music]
hi
welcome back to another episode of big
mood oh my god you guys
look who we have with us
tell them baby tell me who it is i don't
know who is it
it's me
jessica jesse's hair
that movie yeah
jessica
roberts you guys somehow got me back to
l.a yay she loves it i do when i like
when i was flying in i was like
okay cool whatever and then when i was
like driving in my uber to my hotel like
driving through la i was just like
that's how i felt i was like hey
look who's back nibbler come here hey we
also have me hi for the listeners at
home it's gina and then we also have
tiff
tiff is here and nibbler
i know the the audience definitely
misses you and loves you and is always
happy when you're here yes yeah at least
the 10 that are willing to comment for
some reason like me thank you guys
comment let you guys let us know that
we're you're here uh hey so we did this
last time we filmed and we had such a
good time that we're gonna do it again
we're gonna do more am i the [ __ ]
where i read am i the [ __ ] stories
from reddit and then we're all going to
discuss together if this person is an
[ __ ] or not yeah and i like judging
people this is really it's fun that's
why i want to do this so we can judge
other people's mistakes and not feel bad
right you take the spotlight off of our
own mistakes yeah exactly this is an
escape hour you know what though this
was requested by our audience too to see
you specifically jess
they wanted your opinions on these this
would be fun yeah um well i've got
opinions well i know i'm strapped in and
ready to hear them i pulled up a bunch
of them and i was super prepared i did
this
two hours ago
but i'm going into this blind too so i
haven't read these either i kind of just
like read the title okay and you thought
they were juicy enough just from the
title okay all right the first one is am
i the [ __ ] for not taking down my
video that was a gift from my best man
i have a sister that's six years older
than me my parents for years canceled me
last minute because of my sister i have
a basketball game oops sorry sister
doesn't feel like going out i'm
graduating nope sorry sister had a bad
day at work oh hell no they all missed
major and smaller events in my life
because of her meltdowns
i'm at the love of my life we decide to
tie the knot from the beginning i told
my parents how i am worried my sister
will ruin another special moment in my
life my mom told me over and over again
it would not happen the day of my
wedding i received a voicemail from my
mom saying they wouldn't come because my
sister's dog was sick and she was upset
no way
wait is the sister special needs i'm not
understanding why my sister is like
running every little
[ __ ] event she had a bad day at work but
yeah that's why it doesn't make sense to
me like just for that it doesn't but
even if she has some special needs like
would that still justify that yeah i
mean i could see if like an adult with
special needs is having like a meltdown
then the parents would need to address
it or something and would have to miss
the event right but like a normal human
that's why i'm like
i think you would mention it okay i
think you would you didn't mention it so
yeah she's just a regular girl because
then even if she had special needs like
they would have like support there for
her
always maybe not always because the
government offers a ton of support for
special needs so let's assume she's not
because i think she would include that
you know she's just a
she's a brat okay and her parents spoil
her um
so they said that her sister's dog was
sick and she was upset i was hurt my
best man however is a jokester he took
my phone then went to my fiance and
asked if he could post a video of our
wedding as a gift on social media and
she loved this idea
i loved the fiance the fiance
i had no idea about it until i came home
our honeymoon was at a lakeside cabin so
i had no cell service
the post caption was quote my best
friend he's an amazing person even as if
his parents never show up for him
the video was still pictures of us next
to her parents me on the dance floor
cutting the cake where you would
normally see both parents in wedding
pictures the sound behind the video was
my mom's voicemail explaining how they
couldn't come because my sister's dog
was sick
i came home a week later to hundreds of
messages family members from both sides
insisting i take it down i was told my
sister hasn't stopped crying my mom is
refusing to leave the house
i may be the [ __ ] here i didn't take
it down when i got my messages i didn't
call my family back right away i waited
until my vacation time was over at work
and enjoyed my time with my wife in our
new home before i contacted anyone
my dad told me to take down the video it
was quote just a bad night for them they
also said that they will make it up for
me make it up to me and my wife for not
coming my reply was exactly how do you
plan to make up my wedding yeah it's a
once-in-a-lifetime thing yeah you chose
to ignore my feelings on the whole
matter then he just repeated he'll make
it up to me he'll make it up to me i
told him i would take down the video
only when he made up my missing wedding
before missing my wedding flustered we
both hung up the phone before we both
said things we we shouldn't have am i
the [ __ ] here i could have just taken
down the video no
not the [ __ ] at all
your parents are [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i
feel like he even told them for months
ahead of time like i'm afraid my
sister's going to ruin this and you guys
going to miss it and they kept on wait
wait wait why did they miss the wedding
again
she had
her dog was sick and she's upset about
it
why would you miss a wedding for that
that's so weird because you're an
[ __ ]
there's absolutely
no
i can't even fathom someone coming to me
with that excuse like i would
obliterate them
what would what would you say
i don't know honestly like i would
probably go silent for a really long
time because i would i would be trying
to avoid completely like decimating this
person yeah because that is the dumbest
[ __ ] i've ever had you're sad about your
dog i understand that but this is
literally all of this planning all of
this money this only happens one time
you can't redo your wedding yeah that's
one thing for like for the sister right
but then for the parents to use that
excuse me they heard like emotional like
why are they so in charge of making her
happy yeah she's seven years six years
older than so she's a grown adult
she's a grown adult and her parents for
some reason have to cuddle her over
every little tiny thing so much so that
they're willing to miss their son's
wedding that's crazy it's clear that
there's a favorite child here there's
something weird going on in that family
that is so weird people are crazy my mom
like so my aunt was getting married one
year or and then my mom
lives up in the bay area with my sister
and she's like
she told my sister can you watch the dog
while i go to the wedding my sister's
like
no
i'm going to the wedding too
and she's like well i need someone to
watch a dog
because i'm a dog sitter there's my mom
of them thinks her dog is that's not a
dog i don't put a leash on him that's my
son she's one of those okay that's my
son i would never put a leash on him
he's not an animal i wouldn't tie him to
like whatever so he doesn't run off it's
like that's a dog he was she was willing
to have my sister miss our family
wedding
for her dog it was insane so your mom
doesn't trust anyone else with a dog
nope not one person nope
you won't even put them in boarding
that's insane that is so funny
yeah but it's funny how she treats the
dog as if it's her child but doesn't
really care
yeah yeah
wow that's crazy there's something
there's a little mental illness in that
i think a bit of mental illness today i
love it yeah
wait but he's asking if he's the [ __ ]
for not taking that video yeah for
leaving which embarrasses his parents do
his parents deserve
listen
i think he it's fully deserved but also
he is being an [ __ ] about it
but yeah disagree yeah he is it's fully
done it's justified yeah yeah sometimes
you're it's justified to be an [ __ ]
yeah you can be an [ __ ] about this uh
the top comment says not the [ __ ] the
truth hurts sometimes and your parents
and sister just got whammy
that's a very white word
whammy
uh your friend is awesome please leave
the video up yeah i want to watch that
right now
linkedin i want to see that
how it was said what's the
like how is that justified in their own
heads and like oh this is okay we can
miss our son's wedding for this this
reminds me of like a rap song where it's
like this is kind of like the diss track
you know where they have the guy caught
with the voice
a little bit of justice poetic justice
there it is across the board you are not
the [ __ ] um they said your wife and
your friend are true heroes uh not the
[ __ ] but do yourself a favor and cut
them out of your life if you're not
important to them don't let them be
important to you i did this with my
father and i'm better off now
yeah oh okay so okay here we go uh one
of the questions is not the [ __ ] is
your sister development developmentally
disabled way that was my question he
responded saying no she's just super
spoiled she cries on demand big
crocodile crocodile tears whenever she
doesn't get her way or when she isn't in
the spotlight my wife thinks my sister
did this because she asked my own
sisters to be bridesmaids and not my
sister oh she asked her own the
bridesmaid okay yeah for her to be
yeah she asked her own sisters to be the
bridesmaids but not my sister my sister
has done it so many times i think she's
jealous i got married so yeah not
development or no mental illness or
anything i guess no i mean she
definitely has mental illness okay yeah
for sure somewhere somewhere in there
narcissist is not yeah yeah this is not
like normal
i was i was thinking you know more like
special needs were yeah you know but
good god
i mean
how are they planning on making this up
to him yeah
that just sounds empty too it does like
he's probably heard that so many times
he missed a graduation miss like all the
big events you're like you can't because
these are things you can make up
yeah how do you make the dumbest excuses
too like it makes no sense i wonder i
would definitely
cut this guy's family out like if i was
him i would be like if someone did that
to you like if your parents did that to
you right and they were like well i'll
make it up to you can you even think of
something you would want them right like
how do you i wouldn't even have like a
request in order to make this feel
better i do yeah what's your request buy
me a house yeah
money yeah no yeah it's a get me a house
get me a full paid vacation
like
something so if you treat me for me
emotionally then you should just at
least buy me off yeah yeah absolutely if
you want to maintain a better child
parent relationship that would make me
feel better but
it would still cause like irreparable
damage to my feelings towards them and
it just becomes transactional then yeah
for sure so you're like all right buy me
some [ __ ] yeah like if you're gonna be
an [ __ ] and like literally miss out
such an important moment in my life the
least you can do
is buy me something yeah the least you
can do
would you sit in that house though
frustratingly though because like
[ __ ] my parents and like [ __ ] their
money they were never there like do you
think that type of emotion whatever
always pay like if this was like a
common thing where they would always
miss important things and then buy me
off like if it was always like then yeah
it loses its yeah it's like band-aid
power and i guess at that point i would
be feeling frustrated and wouldn't even
want the [ __ ] house like [ __ ] you
keep everything get the [ __ ] out of my
life yeah i would get to that
just don't even bother i definitely
would get to that point if it was like a
like repeated thing but if this was like
all right all these years missing events
never making up
at all like never making it better at
all with nothing not even a a sorry card
or nothing then it's like yeah [ __ ] buy
me a [ __ ] house
i think i would take the house and at
this point it's just like yeah it is the
least you can do if you're not going to
be emotionally there and you want to
make up for it so bad buy me a house it
won't repair the uh the damage
emotionally in our relationship with
that
but you know whatever it's something at
least you tried
you know yeah at least they tried i
guess
but i i wouldn't have any hope of like
them changing their ways at all
yeah i'm trying to think about this too
from the other side like i'm trying to
imagine being these psychotic parents
who only care about one of their
children like
what is it
in them
that makes them not give a [ __ ] about
this one son
like can you imagine yeah can you
imagine like
being a parent and kind of like
not liking one of your kids like is that
possible you think like even if he's
just a normal kid i feel like parents
don't like their kids but it's not
liking them is one thing but not loving
them because it sounds like they don't
even love him
that's [ __ ] cruel yeah yeah because i
guess they're all everyone's like their
own person right so even if you are your
mother son or whatever you could just
not really get along not really but then
you would think there's still some duty
to show up and they don't even have that
yeah yeah
which is crazy that's crazy to me like
when people
play favoritism like that yeah
yeah so unless the kids [ __ ] like
insane like
punches you in the face and all that
[ __ ] it's like okay i can see why you
know so you know like in step brothers
right the movie step brother yes yeah
like imagine if your son is one of those
kids right like would you miss their
wedding
like
sorry my dog is sick you know what my
sister you know like like making up
excuses at that point though it's those
parents cultivated that in their child
so
i feel like so for me for example
i think there's a huge chunk of it that
is nurture
as well as nature there's a huge chunk
of nature that i can't help that are in
my my own my two sons that i can't do
anything about that's just how they're
gonna be
but the nurture part is like what kind
of men do they grow up to be that's
my
doing like if they're growing up and
they're they turn out to be like the
stepbrother kids that's my [ __ ] fault
as a parent yeah for sure i think those
kind of parents they would go to the
wedding anyways because their son
they do everything for their son already
yeah so they're definitely gonna go yeah
yeah
okay next one am i the [ __ ] for
yelling at my wife for drinking
here we
go i am a recovering alcoholic my father
was an alcoholic when i was a child and
i guess i caught it from him i've been
sober for about a year now and i attend
this recovery group once a week that is
held by a mormon church oh boy
oh this one's getting prickly yeah i've
been gaining an interest in their
beliefs and have been considering
conversion but that's another
conversation
my wife went out with her friends this
weekend i found out from her friend's
instagram post that she had been
drinking she held a glass of wine in the
photo but she didn't appear drunk when
she got home i saw the post today and
i'm gonna be honest i freaked out she
has been so helpful and supportive
during my recovery and i can't believe
she would do this to me i confronted her
as soon as i saw it and she told me that
because she wasn't drinking around me it
wasn't an issue i told her that when we
got married we promise to support each
other through everything and this isn't
being supportive and a direct violation
of our vows
she told me to get over myself and i
lost it and i told her that
she was a bad wife and that she wasn't
committed to us in our relationship
we've been together for four years
married for one i told her that if she
was pregnant i wouldn't eat all this
food she couldn't eat just so i can be
supportive and she told me that she
wouldn't expect that from me so i can't
expect her to be sober and that i was
being an [ __ ] after that i just left
and contacted the group leader from my
recovery group he let me chill at his
house while i cool down am i the [ __ ]
yes yes
yes you're an [ __ ]
absolutely she was literally
in her own private time with her friends
not anywhere near him not triggering you
not like it's not her fault that you
went ahead and was being all nosy
looking at other people's pictures yeah
she she
also that's not even a discussion that
they had clearly if not she would have
known and wouldn't like they would have
talked about that the ground rules yeah
the ground sobriety exactly including
the fact that she can't ever
engage because it's going to trigger him
yeah i
he's he's a recovering alcoholic not her
she can be supportive but it doesn't
mean she has to fully like change
something that didn't even affect her
like it doesn't affect alcohol doesn't
affect her it was him so you can't
expect everyone around him
to that's kind of like those like
hardcore vegans that when you're eating
meat around them they get pissed at you
it's like i'm a vegan how dare you eat
meat near me but in this case like
they're not eating it around him yeah
they have like sugar and he's commenting
at home yeah up there yeah
what yeah how about you you're
hesitating what do you think
is he an [ __ ] for yelling at his wife
over this [ __ ] absolutely i'm just more
concerned that he's not
he's not going about his sobriety in a
healthy way so i feel like this is going
to really tear them apart if he doesn't
figure out how to get more support in
the proper way like i think it's great
that he's like
you like seeking out religion and stuff
like that maybe that'll help him too and
like take the focus so much off of like
what his wife's actions are like and
bring them back down to what his are
because really at the end of the day
like addicts i feel like a lot of times
blame every everything else around them
for why they have to use
but it's really it's all inside of them
right like they're the ones that choose
i'm i i i hesitated only because i'm
just like man
i feel like this is a struggle and he's
just so far behind
where he needs to be in order to like
get sober in the right way like i feel
like he's just gonna this is not gonna
go well for him like where he's at
mentally like his sobriety still blaming
it on other people and taking it out on
her and expecting her to have to like
mirror every single thing he does in
order for him to hold it together
it's like this is it scares me i just
that relationship i feel like and
they're married so
there's no getting out of it right i
don't know i'm just
i'm very fearful for how he's coming at
this
i
i don't know how i feel about
alcohol
or like recovery or what is it recovery
um
programs
with i feel like it's under the guise of
a recovery program when it's a real
religion thing yeah i don't like when
they include religion into it yeah like
you should go to a proper alcoholic aa
is all like based on god it's always
non-denominational but it's religious so
it's like you can't really find very
many like entirely secular really yeah a
lot of like aaa like all the steps and
all that like as my mom went through it
it's all like god higher power based
stuff it's not specifically
one religion or another but a lot of
times people will fall into one because
of that oh weird i don't know
oh but yeah so that's tough to find i
mean there's probably facilities that he
could go to if he like had to go to like
an actual rehab yeah and like maybe
there's some you could find but i feel
like a lot of it stems around like
finding a higher power a different like
higher purpose something like outside of
yourself in order to help you overcome
that addiction yeah so
religion is often a lot here
yeah and mormons are weird too
yeah
yeah i just think it's he was an [ __ ]
for it and he shouldn't force people
to abide by his rules for himself
because he's the one
who's a recovering addict and not her
like like what if what if casey was like
well okay what does casey like what does
he love food food
right like what's a specific food uh he
likes barbecuing a lot
yeah so if he's like i have to get off
barbecue because my doctor said it's not
healthy for me it'd be [ __ ] up if he
saw you eating barbecue in my house and
be like tim what the [ __ ] you know yeah
can you see a little bit though how it's
like triggering so it's like
i'm trying so hard to
like change myself and it's almost like
you're laughing in my face
and not not like not suffering with me a
little bit i think like i can see where
they're coming from it's not right i can
see where they're coming from but it's
just like because man i wish it's like
it's it's like a codependent right it's
like i wish that you would take this
journey with me because i'm not strong
enough to take it on my own so like i
need you to also
behave in a way where you understand
this the suffering that i'm going
through like the sacrifices that i'm
making to you it's not that big of a
deal right because you don't have the
addiction problem so you can have a
drink and then it's not a big deal i
can't and so it's almost like i kind of
see like where that selfish little you
know like piece of them is coming from
and i feel like that's fine
if there's a conversation yeah like you
can't just blindly expect the other
person to know exactly how you're
feeling your expectations about it
because like when he used a pregnancy
example
like during my pregnancy with luca like
casey himself volunteered where he was
like i'm not going to eat sushi your
whole pregnancy i'm also going to
continue to cut coffee even though we
already got pregnant because we were
cutting coffee and alcohol to get
pregnant yeah but then once i already
was pregnant he's like i'm still gonna
stick to it yeah and
he didn't but that like it that didn't
upset me because i'm like no you get to
you enjoy yourself you eat some sushi
that's fine
the only thing i did i remember one time
i was like
well just this one meal like can you not
eat it in front of me because i really
do miss sushi like i can't have yeah
but like i communicated that instead of
being like letting him
or like saying it's fine go ahead and
eat sushi and then i'm over here fuming
by myself i'll piss like how dare he eat
sushi when i said like which just makes
no [ __ ] sense so like for him to not
communicate that with his wife at all
and expect her and assume she will yeah
and assume that she will have these
exact same thoughts
it's just really [ __ ] up i don't know
it's like she he set her up for failure
yeah i'm worried for them um but i feel
like i understand why he has that
reaction and i don't think he's an
[ __ ] for having those feelings but i
think he's an [ __ ] for the way he
carried it out by yelling at his wife
and like making her feel like [ __ ] and
all of that but it's like this could be
a learning lesson like i wonder how his
support team responded to that
no i know
yeah okay so top comment says you're the
[ __ ] this is not about you she didn't
do this to you she did it for herself
when you were safely far away yeah it's
good she supports you spouses should
support each other but at the end of the
day this is your affliction and it's not
responsible oh and it's not reasonable
for you to criticize her drinking she's
not the one with the problem she
suffered enough from your alcoholism
without you abusing her on top of it
you're on thin ice you should watch out
you need to apologize um i agree
and then someone said yeah i pinged my
spidey sense that a religion that very
explicitly calls for wives to submit to
their husbands in all aspects of life is
something
opie the original poster who yelled at
his wife for daring to drink alcohol
with her friends outside the home is
very interested in that he's in
interested in mormon that's true
there is a link there
also mormons don't drink alcohol at all
like it's like that could be even more
of like a self-hating thing that's
feeding into this if he like starts
feeling that pressure from the church if
he gets into it
that could make it worse that's a him
it's a selfish thing like i remember
when i met you guys up in hawaii
with
well i was there with my boyfriend and i
and then i ran into you guys and i told
him like oh you know i'm going to extend
my say because i want to hang out you
guys
and then he's like no you have to go
home
even though we lived in different cities
yeah he was flying home separately i was
flying home separately he's like no you
have to go home like why he goes because
if i have to go home and work you should
go home too i'm like
that's really i paid for my own ticket
i'm not even flying home with you i
don't even live with you in the same in
the same city i can get if you guys live
together yeah and he's like yeah will
you yeah
well i wouldn't have one too yeah
to be like no you need to go home to la
when i live in a different city yeah
anyway
and it was one of those like i have to
go home and work and suffer and be
miserable so you have to go home too
it's like it's like serious oh yeah oh
we got into an argument about it oh wow
and then why didn't you do you have to
do it yeah
like
i'm i paid for my ticket you don't get a
say
in anything and you how long did you
date him after that
like two years two years after and off
on and off he was on and on for a long
time yeah do you know yeah look i was
just glad
we've grown
a lot okay if anyone tells you anything
okay so just as a side note i was uh
texting this guy that i just smashed
with on a dating site or something and
then i was saying like oh i'm watching
this thing on netflix and he goes oh
i've already seen it you should just
turn it off
no
was it like i've already seen it it's
bad you should just no he was just like
i've already seen it just turn it off
like i think he was wrong he was trying
to get me to come out with him or
something so he was thought he was being
cute but i was like this is not cute no
because this is like this is demanding
step one of
and i didn't respond to him the rest of
the night and he even went like jessica
dot dot dot like a few hours later like
ew and i was like no no you deleted the
threads [ __ ] [ __ ] weirdo weird but
yeah i know people that are controlling
like that that's crazy that's the whole
misery once company they just want you
to yeah suffer with it it's not a good
sign
i you know and i totally agree that this
guy is an [ __ ] and his
i mean that's i can't date someone who
is an alcoholic i've tried
like you know someone who's in recovery
especially the beginning of the recovery
like i feel like those
people
need to be alone for like a good two
three years figure out their sobriety on
their own
it's hard though because they're already
married but
that's just a recipe i can't even date
someone who drinks a lot and not even
just
a
an alcoholic an addict but just someone
who drink who likes to drink well they
might be an alcoholic just a functioning
one
because like most people aren't drinking
all the time right unless they're an
alcoholic but it's just that some people
they don't ruin their life right they're
a high functioning
low like well i mean in this case though
like consequences type of drinker or in
the case that's in my brain i mean that
person did ruin his life with the way
that he would react when he was under
the influence
relationships and stuff yeah just yeah
that's just it's true i think that they
would be classified as an alcoholic in
my opinion i think alcoholics are like i
don't know how they classify like you're
drinking every day even alone even no i
mean drinkers are also alcoholics so
like they'll go you know a week or two
without drinking oh really drink like oh
they'll drink like a [ __ ] hole
i'm like yeah that can also classify as
alcohol you if you don't drink it all
and then the next [ __ ] like one
weekend you just down like a whole thing
of vodka like that's also signs of an
alcoholic see yeah oh do you wish your
luggage didn't just scream oh i'm on a
business trip well guess what it doesn't
have to with base you can get chic
affordable travel bags and accessories
that look good and are packed with
function base was created by actress
shea mitchell to make sleek and
affordable bags luggage and accessories
designed to help you travel effortlessly
while still looking fashionable bass is
thought of everything you could ever
want in a piece of luggage 360 degree
gliding wheels a cushion handle a
built-in weight indicator washable bags
for your dirty clothes and all the
interior pockets you need to keep
organized their luggage comes in
multiple sizes and colors and for
shorter trips the weekender bag is super
functional and even has a place to store
your shoes separately every piece is
made to look better with miles so you
don't have to worry about it in cargo or
overhead and base has over thirty
thousand five star reviews whether
you're packing for a quick trip or
looking to breeze through the security
line base has your personal items
covered i just received um a piece of
luggage from base and i have to say it's
gorgeous it's beautiful it's trending
everyone loves it and there's absolutely
a million reasons why you guys have to
try this luggage if you're looking to
replace your luggage give base a try
right now base is offering our listeners
15 off your first purchase by visiting
basetravel.com
big mood go to basetravel.com big mood
for 15
off your first purchase and that's
spelled b e
i s
travel dot com slash big moot get you
some luggage it's beautiful all right
next one am i the [ __ ] for cutting
off support to my daughter i have three
children with my ex tracy the children's
names are michael linda and victoria
they're all in their
mid to late 20s we split because tracy
had an affair with stan
to whom she is now married we never
share with the kids the reason for the
divorce as i didn't want them to blame
either of us well this backfired as the
kids saw their mom move out of the house
into a small apartment and me keep
living in the house and remarried two
years after the divorce
so they saw me as the bad guy driving oh
damn
stan and tracy let them pretty much do
whatever they wanted and i had to be the
disciplinarian who made sure homework
was done appointments were made and
deadlines were met oh wow you did the
thing that like so many women have to do
all the time
you're
i had to throw that in there but i'm
glad that he's being the responsibility
so funny i just had to get that a shitty
mom yeah she is she's being terrible but
like think about he's complaining over
some [ __ ] that literally so many women
have to deal with yeah i'm sure but it
is a pain when the other day
the dad [ __ ] girl you're speaking
you're preaching to the choir like
literally this is my experience
i get it
now you see him
i get it but he should be the
responsibility i know he's not but it's
funny to be like now you see what women
go through
but anyways continue i'm on your side
i'm on your side sir
my two oldest eventually came to realize
that i was not the bad guy
not the bad guy my son when he found out
that his mother had put nothing away for
him for college for him as outlined in
our divorce decree and she told him to
take out loans my daughter when she
realized that her grades were going to
keep her out of her desired program in
school
my youngest never came around so it was
a surprise when her boyfriend asked for
my blessing to ask for her hand when i
expressed that i didn't think she'd care
about my blessing he said she insisted
on it
she began spending time with me being
polite to my wife and it felt wonderful
to have my daughter back i went with
them to book the venue and they'll be
getting married next summer i paid the
deposit and the first installment
i noticed that she was becoming less
communicative again
recently ignoring my texts or giving one
word replies and not coming over as much
on monday my son sent me my son sent me
a post from instagram my youngest had an
engagement party this weekend to which i
was not invited one of the photos was
her with stan and it read anyone can be
a father it takes a real man to be a dad
oh no so she used him for like wedding
deposit stuff damn
that's shady and then she shaded him on
the internet the caption said this
amazing guy has been my dad for 15 years
even though he didn't have to be i'm so
blessed to have him walk me down the
aisle next year
daddy's girl
no
step daddies girl
my kids wanted for nothing their entire
lives because i never let them go
without even when they wouldn't talk to
me i made sure their needs were met i
texted tracy to ask why i didn't i was
not included
she replied that victoria didn't want my
wife there because she wanted a
drama-free day where's victoria oh sorry
sometimes
i texted my ex-wife
and my ex-wife said my daughter didn't
want my wife there yeah because she's a
mom yeah the stepmom she wanted a drama
free day my wife has literally never
started drama in her life i asked if
stan and i would both be walking down
the aisle tracy didn't respond but
victoria called me up to manchester
united that's so sweet of him to even
offer [ __ ] yeah
yeah the [ __ ]
she's nice he got walked all over
tracy didn't respond but my daughter
called me up demanding who to know what
my problem was i repeated my question
and she replied no
stan her dad would be walking her down
the aisle i told her if that's what she
wanted
i would be fine with it i told her to
let stan know the next payment for the
wedding is due in november
stan and tracy do not have the money for
this wedding and think i'm being an
[ __ ]
um my blood is boiling my wife says if i
do this my daughter will never speak to
me again
that is so [ __ ] what all my other
kids are on my side good yeah
dude
she used herself at his heartstrings for
money
[ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah cut her cut her off
never speak to her again like this
and then the other two siblings if
they're on if they're on dad's side
i wonder what they're saying i wonder
what they're saying to their little
sister to be like what the [ __ ] are you
doing sister's probably not listening
wow that's really [ __ ] up and then the
white the ex-wife would be like
yeah
you know my husband that i cheated on
you with yeah what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] oh my god i'm so mad for him holy
[ __ ]
you know i know i like i understand when
parents want to shelter their kids from
marital issues and i think that's the
right move to make but when there's
something that's like
done right like we're getting a divorce
we're gonna move into separate houses
this is what happened you know your mom
was the one that decided that she didn't
want to be in this relationship anymore
i feel like the kids need to know that
kind of stuff they don't need to know
that your mom was
sucking a dick in the back
but the kids need to know the truth like
shielding them from that i feel like
sets you up for like the kids kids will
understand
a lot more than you think they will and
they deserve to know the truth of what's
going on too so like even just starting
this from them being young right
the house split up visually it looks
like the dad just kicked out the mom
like you know like
tell them the truth yeah but like in a
way that they can handle right like your
mom wanted to leave
um i'm still gonna do everything i can
to support you guys i was just it wasn't
like this way i love you guys you're my
i'm always going to be there for you you
know you can tell the kids what happened
like your mom kind of [ __ ] up but it's
okay
um both parents like you but then the
other party can be so [ __ ] immature
because i've seen families where
hey your mom cheated and the mom would
be like no no i didn't no like they'll
just lie and try to make the dad the
villain be like no he [ __ ] on me like
parents lie to their kids or you know
like parents like [ __ ] talk
the other parents to their kids you know
so i can see why i can i can see this
woman doing that
and turning his first shirt but he i
guess he just let that narrative like
live is what i'm saying is like
if you know that shit's [ __ ] up
you want to protect your kids from drama
that's perfectly fine they don't need
all the details but not letting them
really know what happened at all yeah in
a way is doing yourself and them a
disservice
no but gina's right too though like i
totally
i can see that playing out that way too
because
i mean like i said i'm in my own
situation right with my 14 year old
and his dad tells him a lot of things
from our past
that makes isaac look at me
in a different light where i'm like
you don't know the whole truth like you
don't know everything but then like at
the same time i have to hold myself back
because now it's gotten to a point where
isaac and like his dad is his everything
and anything that i say
it's like i'm lying i'm wrong because
there's no way is it because you're not
telling him the truth about things about
his dad too
so it's like he's just getting all this
[ __ ] from his dad about you and then
you're like i'm gonna protect my son so
that he can still love his dad yeah and
then you're just like martyr now yeah no
literally that's the case and now like
it's just it's really [ __ ] up but i
i'm holding out on the hopes that when
he gets older
and when i feel like he can he can be re
he's only 14 like he's not ready to hear
everything yeah that he needs to hear
and so when he's at a good age where i'm
like okay i'll tell you everything now
i'm hoping at that point he can like
piece things together and see the the
clear picture yeah
but until then like right now i'm just
i'm bad guy yeah i've been bad guy
because in our home i have to be the
disa discipline ordinary person
i have to make sure that he's being
responsible and does all like chores and
grades everything
now like you know doing extracurricular
activities in school like i'm the one
that's like no you're not gonna quit
you're not going to be a quitter yeah
and he [ __ ] hates my guts it sounds
similar like like the kids especially
even the younger literally like they got
to go back to the other parents house
yeah than the steps that's what they're
telling you whatever preaching to the
choir jessica i'm literally living this
[ __ ] life right now it's hell
it's [ __ ] hell and i don't know how
to help
me in this situation you're like someone
help me yeah please help me my 14 year
old hates me and i don't know how to
like that's i mean honestly i feel like
i hated my parents when i was 14 too
like i i think that's a phase some of it
is just a phase like and it would be any
teenager like pick anyone out of the
crowd and they're gonna hate you for
some reason it's just a phase they have
to go through in order to like create
independence right like yeah i have to
sever myself a little bit become a man i
can't just be a [ __ ] mama's boy yeah
or whatever so he's probably just going
through this phase right where and then
like maybe his dad has some sort of uh
charisma that he's drawn to kind of like
the andrew tate [ __ ] [ __ ] like funny
he's not the best
role model but it's kind of attracting
him for some reason it's helping him
kind of be a little bit stronger like
get more confidence as a man or whatever
then he'll figure out realistic
[ __ ] in life later hopefully i think as
long as you're around i don't know as
long as you're around no because it
literally gets so hard to a point where
i'm like
is is there any like what's the finish
line here because like should i even
[ __ ] stick around for that like what
the [ __ ] men
what the [ __ ] is the feeling they're
still grow up and figure it out i had to
figure that out yeah you know my parents
were the same way
um where
you know one parent was talking [ __ ]
about the other i'm like yeah i [ __ ]
that other parent and then i grew up i'm
like i turn around i'm like dude you are
the [ __ ] up woman this whole time you
know your kids are eating manipulate
until they
get a mind of their own which
you know your brain's not fully formed
you're 25 so just give it another 10
years yeah but this [ __ ] is getting
married yeah this [ __ ] [ __ ] is
getting married yeah and she's literally
she wants her stepdad yeah
well it's like i also wonder too i'm
like
you are the one that creates the
relationship
between yourself and your children right
so it's like has he not done enough
other than just being a disciplinarian
and i'm not i hope that none of this
crosses over to you no it definitely i
just because that's what i was saying
earlier where i'm like there's a good
chunk of nature and a good chunk of
nurture and i know i've [ __ ] up in the
literature with isaac i know for a fact
i have and so like now it's kind of
biting me in the ass and i'm like well
now i have to kind of
ride the wave because i don't know
what else to do to make it better like
i'm trying to
do things
to help the situation but i feel like
it's kind of like one of those things
where it's like no matter what i do it's
being a parent is probably one of the
worst [ __ ] things because there's no
right answer yeah there's no right
answer and there's no like guidebook no
at all it's an it's everyone has their
opinion it's just like running a country
right like we all have our own opinions
on how to run this country there's
probably good things that could happen
from these opinions and good things that
but then we're somewhere in the middle
and there's still going to be [ __ ]
[ __ ] up like there's no possible way
to do it right
so it's just like trying to find a
balance right like you get too far this
way oop let's pop it back this way like
if you're too much of a disciplinarian
let's pop it back over to maybe i can be
the fun mom a little bit if i'm the fun
mom too much we need to get back over
here being disciplinary like i imagine
it's only just like constantly trying to
like
come back from too much in one direction
or another but then so i just can't
imagine though like me being a daddy's
girl i'm like how
has her relationship with her actual
father
gotten that back like what happened
there like no older but maybe it's just
like
she wasn't around enough because like
the older kids are on his side so it's
like they had access and exposure to him
right maybe the younger one the younger
one didn't really get enough of that so
she just latched on to the new one right
yeah that's not necessarily his fault
but it's like i don't know
if she's doing that type of
[ __ ] that like i could see her maybe not
having that good of a relationship with
her dad
and like wanting maybe her stepdad to
walk because she's closer he's the one
that was actually there every single day
that's fine but then going on social
media yeah and being like this is my
real dad it's different to be a [ __ ]
sperm donor from being a [ __ ] father
you know like just her attitude about it
like that warrants a all right in the
comments
yeah absolutely to use him for the money
too
yeah he was getting all excited that his
daughter was coming around
he put some cash down and then she
disappears like
parent or not as a human being they're
all adults like that's not how you treat
someone right uh reddit's saying you're
not the [ __ ] can you just cancel the
venue and get a refund if so please do
yeah he should totally do his name no
that's two oh my
here we did this i'm not giving anything
else don't [ __ ] ask me for [ __ ] like
there's no reason to go in and try to
ruin it because then it just like
justifies them yeah thinking that
they're right you know what i mean
don't let them think they're right yeah
just be like the bigger people you know
i have problems with my forcing yourself
just let just be the bigger person be
like all right well i tried to help you
using this route anyway yeah yeah
because that's why he's like the next
payment is on this date yeah like
let your real dad then pay for it
you want to call him real dad you like
him so much
all right the next one we have is even
the money thing by the way okay whatever
yeah
i was like oh whatever [ __ ] conniving
am i the [ __ ] for throwing my
siblings in foster care so i can have a
better life whoa throwing my siblings in
foster care yeah
throwing i know just chucking them in
there well let's hear the whole story
yeah i have roughly too many siblings
and even more siblings probably too many
too many
between my parents and my latest
stepfather we have eight kids living
here holy [ __ ] damn myself being 19
three half siblings on my mom's side
four step siblings and one full sister
who's six years old
things have never been from nineteen
baby [ __ ] yeah right that's a huge
gap where is it all kids come from 19 to
six yeah eight kids in total so he has
one full sister things have never been
particularly good or stable but now
we're at rock bottom my mother and
stepfather are going to be going away
for a long time and everyone's in a rush
to get older then that's what it sounds
like
where the [ __ ] they going no idea for a
long time prison right let's assume damn
and everyone is in a rush to get all
these kids into homes i'm the one who
only one who's over 18 so everyone wants
me to do it i don't want to
i've gotten an opportunity my
grandmother on my father's side offered
to have me and my full-blood sister the
six-year-old uh move in with her and
even pay for me to go to college the
thing is she lives several states away i
talked to social workers about this and
got the answer that i could move with my
little sister without a problem because
her parents were able to voluntarily
give up me or gave give me guardianship
of her and of course i'm her full sister
the rest i can only take in if i stayed
in the state because they would be a
full foster care placement though
i'm sorry but being forced to stay here
will destroy my future i could
definitely survive but i would be stuck
in a horrible place working paycheck to
paycheck i can never have a real life i
made the obvious choice the social
workers were nice enough to arrange it
to where me and my sister
weren't just standing in front of them
during the pickup
but obviously they know exactly why
they're now in care the four of them
that have phones have been texting me
and calling me non-stop some of them for
help and some of them just scream at me
for abandoning them
i know the system is going to be really
bad for them because of where they are
and their ages but i just can't do it i
can't blow this this is mine and my
sister's first chance for a real life
and i feel like i owed both of us to
make it right to take that chance am i
in the wrong here the kids my mom think
i am my grandmother thinks i should have
done something but can't say what and
wouldn't let them in her house even if
it could happen the only person who
doesn't think worse of me is my
six-year-old sister who thinks
who says she likes the quiet but
obviously doesn't know the full story am
i the [ __ ] damn
that's rough that's so [ __ ] up i mean
okay
it's not her responsibility to take care
of children that she didn't have right
she's still a child herself she's 18 or
19 19
but i can see how all those kids are
like
you know
need something
more than what the state's going to give
them which is going to be a bunch of
probably really shitty families to live
with for a little while i'm curious to
know where are the rest of the family
members in this picture right there
probably just is none i mean it sounds
like if the parents are going to jail
there's probably like
no one around yeah because these are
steps um three of them are halves four
of them are steps yeah and then one full
sister
yeah
that's rough because then where's their
parents
like right the other the other parent
yeah they're obviously not in the
picture since the foster care system is
where they're going so it's like a total
total [ __ ] show i i would say like
you're not as attached to your steps
right because you're like these are
strangers yeah exactly like i've known
you for two years like why do i have to
change my whole life for you right yeah
yeah this one's wrong i i feel like i
probably would have done the same thing
like take my full-blooded sister and
just go um
not that the full-blooded sister means
anything more than the other ones but
it kind of does you know what i mean
it's like this is my actual sister all
these other ones i don't really know you
like there's got to be someone else that
can figure this out for you guys but
she's the youngest
we have the best chance
so it's kind of like a survive mentality
kind of thing like when you're down that
bad like you have to figure out
how to just make it out alive it seems
like
and like in order to clear her
conscience i would assume like try to go
to college try to like do something
maybe like to help them later like
someone's got to get out right in order
to like if you all stay drowning yeah
then no one wins
if you can get out if you can go to
college if you can get some sort of job
that can maybe help them in the future
or at least just teach them how to
do better later if they're younger
enough like maybe she could help them
with college later or something like
this is
freaking tough this is like yeah this is
so many people's lives like
just a mess yeah kids so many kids uh
the top comment says not the [ __ ]
your siblings should be met at your
parents not you they're the ones putting
everyone in this position you are 19 in
no way can or should you be a parent to
that many kids
don't fault yourself you're put in the
situation not just them good luck to all
of you it's such a [ __ ] horrible
like i feel like imagine you see them
later on and they're like i was [ __ ]
abused and [ __ ] yeah exactly that's
the thing is like because you're you are
an adult right you're 18 you're like i
could do something about this
technically
you can't
you can't stop yourself from having
culpability and whatever happens to them
now through this system yeah it's still
the pain so that's why i'm like in my
mind i'm trying to think of how she can
do better later it's just like right now
she doesn't have she's nothing she can
what can she do right now like go work
at [ __ ] mcdonald's and like struggle
to like or go get an education and like
try to help them later like i don't know
what the answer is but that's like
you're all gonna drown together or
someone has to get on the life raft yeah
yeah and you know how she said that like
the four of them keep blowing up her
face oh yep uh yep it's right they're
going to prison prison yeah obviously
yeah like i hope she's at least trying
to communicate with the ones that are
hitting her up i think that she should
you know i'm sorry i'm trying like i
really can't but you know what i'm not
going to forget about you i'm still
going to like stay in their lives yeah
like talk to them every so often like
keep updated like if they're in a really
terrible [ __ ] situation like maybe
you can help try to you know this we
need a new placement here this is bad
like be someone yeah like the advocate
help kind of push but like she really
has to she can't raise those kids to get
out and get on her own life raft i think
yeah for sure i think that would help a
lot because if the
kids call her and be like this foster
home is awful then yeah she can help out
and call cps yeah because a lot of times
kids in the system don't have anyone to
advocate for them like
there's not enough workers or they're
just not hurt or something so that's the
least that she could do and i think
that's also the most that she could do
yeah all right last one
am i the [ __ ] for saying i told you
so at my sister-in-law and brother's
wedding i 27 year old female have known
my sister-in-law for three years she's
the type of person that always needs to
be right and needs to be in charge of
everything she's very demanding as well
my sister-in-law's family members are
very disrespectful and rude they don't
clean up after themselves expect
everyone to act like maids or servants
around them and they think very highly
of themselves they can never be wrong
and think they can do no wrong well
that's where she gets it from
because of this my sister-in-law's
family
don't really punish their kids like they
have no consequences they aren't even
like the gentle parenting type either my
sister-in-law's sister has a son and
he's extremely chaotic he throws
tantrums if he doesn't get something and
he has to be a center of attention 24 7.
when there are birthdays he man these
people with their grammar is terrible
i'm i'm struggling here jesus christ
when there are birthdays he needs a gift
or opens the gifts and needs to blow out
the candles damn dude
[ __ ] those kind of kids
oh my god it's frustrating which is why
i'm not usually around a family
gatherings and other stuff i was at my
sister-in-law since her friend cancelled
on her and i was helping make
invitations
i saw one of the i saw one of the names
were sister-in-law's nephew i asked if
she wanted him to go and she said yeah
she then asked why so i told her why i
talked about his tantrums and how he'll
probably throw a fit during the
reception and other stuff
she got mad and said that she didn't
know what i was talking about she told
my family and her sister which caused
her sister to write me a message saying
how i was wrong and other stuff like
that oh my god well day the wedding
comes everyone comes in happy except
nephew he's crying and is about to throw
a fit when my sister-in-law came out he
literally started screaming the poor
pastor had to stop and wait for the
parents to leave
during the after party ruined the walk
out
during the after party he was back again
and crying when they were cutting the
cake he screamed extremely loud he
pushed my sister-in-law who was holding
a glass of wine and spilled on her
so she started crying oh no she turned
around to leave and i looked at her and
i said i told you so and she started
crying even more
when i got home my mom called me
extremely immature and wants me to
apologize so am i the [ __ ] no
that was extremely mature why are
children allowed at weddings first of
all no children wedding every time
i see a wedding invite and you haven't
seen this guy in a suit
he's cute as [ __ ] if i see a wedding
invite and it doesn't say
no children please i don't want to go
i really don't want to go yeah like
children should not be at a wedding um
it's an adult event
i disagree
they have children's tables they also
have children activities so there needs
to be someone also children are part of
your family they're important members of
your family
wrangling them somewhere else then for
like the most serious part such as the
walk out like the valve no the parents
need to have their kids on check i fully
agree to that but i don't agree with the
no children wedding but if it's your
wedding
and you don't want like you know i i'm
not the type that's like no you must
have children at your wedding and if you
don't i'm not gonna go like i'm not like
that
i am but the opposite way yeah yeah i
don't want to go if you have kids
i'm not like that but like for example i
had a friend who got married last year
and she was saying like she didn't want
kids at her wedding either
and that her whole family they were just
raining down on her like you're so mean
how could you not have kids at your
family i mean at your wedding like you
know we're um we're all a part of this
wedding and how can like i don't have a
babysitter so that means you're not
gonna allow me to go or whatever so like
she was getting so much drama from her
entire family and at that point i was
like
but it's your wedding yeah you get to
decide what you want at your wedding if
you don't you don't want your girls at
your wedding then don't [ __ ] have two
you're paying for this party exactly
that's what i said i'm like who's paying
for this yeah are they paying for your
wedding no it's your wedding don't have
kids if you don't want kids but besides
that i think kids can have a place at a
wedding if they're parents it has to be
wrangling them it needs to be there
needs to be like dedicated like wedding
nannies or something like i'm gonna have
the kids kind of over here
adults are drinking it's like you know
like it's just weird the kids are just
[ __ ] screaming breaking [ __ ] it's
like
it's a it's a chaotic place in this case
it's a very like
it's this is one kid that's specifically
like redheaded stepchild like ruining
everything how would you go about
telling your family or friends like hey
uh can you maybe not your kid yeah you
know how would you go about doing a good
one because like what if you have
another like what if they're kids that
you like love you know yeah and like you
want them there you know and you love
their family you know the kids a good
kid well what about having a
conversation where it's like
you know i love your kid you know i do
yeah so you also know how your kid can
get no my kid can never
nice yeah fine then it's like okay well
you're not self-aware
and so if you're being a really bad
friend my son is great what are you
saying about my son right now okay well
here's don't think you wanna
listen i'm going to point out all these
instances of when this kid was being a
[ __ ] demon she was like you're like a
kid kids are going to be kids tiff okay
well if you can wrangle your child i
don't want your kid at my wedding period
no seriously like i feel like whoever's
paying for this is
has final say it's my [ __ ] money
it's that's because i even asked her
because um my friend right she was like
yeah well you know my
my mom is like pitching in a little bit
for this and she definitely wants like
kids or whatever i'm like well
that's a different discussion because
now she's paying her how much is she
just paying for the cake or is she
paying for a bunch of [ __ ] i feel like
it's like them paying for it is like a
gift to you though like a gift can't
come with with conditions you know like
it's still your wedding day and if they
make the decision to gift you this it
doesn't mean that they get a say like
this is not a joint decision
if i had kids right and i was giving
them fifty thousand dollars for a
wedding and they wanted to hold it
somewhere that i thought was [ __ ]
terrible like say they want to have an
alaskan wedding it's gonna be difficult
for us to all get up there
we all have to take a [ __ ]
one of those shitty little planes to get
to the i would be like can we not like
i'm paying for this can i veto this
decision to have it like i would have
some stipulation yeah but i feel like
it's like it's still their day it is
there you can't buy in to make choices
you know like you're not an investor
here yeah
like
we could have a lovely wedding somewhere
else yeah you know yeah yeah no the
whole i told you so though oh that must
have felt so good i know but for sure
she was like
yeah like kind of like there's chaos all
around and then she's just like i told
you so
um the top comment says you're the
[ __ ] yeah this is absolutely this is
absolutely a you're not wrong you're
just an [ __ ] situation it doesn't
matter that you're right there's no need
to be that person in the moment i
disagree
i disagree i think if someone's not
self-aware someone's not aware of like
how bad their little [ __ ] kid is
they need to have that rattled into
their brain yeah
they need to know
i feel like there is a better way of
doing it like no there's not like okay
so there's like a more tactical way of
doing it right okay
tell me like instead of instead of like
told you so like you could have been
like oh my god it's all over i told you
not to invite them like i told you come
on you like or like i'm more like
concerned like oh empathetic
aggressiveness
this kid is a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] but
then the wife would be more inclined to
be like oh you're right when you're
being like when you're no just makes
more excuses we keep [ __ ] we keep
putting little band-aids and [ __ ]
covering our eyes with petroleum jelly
we're like no i don't see that kid being
bad no it's fine isn't it no that's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] kid he sucks don't
[ __ ] bring him next time yeah figure
your kid out discipline him do something
he sucks he does suck
and i vote that one because yes you're
right and also yes you're right yeah
just a little bit of tact that's all
because if you really want something
they're just like tacked with that
little [ __ ] [ __ ]
ruin the wedding there's no tax why does
it deserve tax i guess the goal here
like is there there's different goals
right the goal if the goal is see i'm
gonna let you know that i'm right rub it
in rub it in and be like i told you so
but if the goal is to really teach the
bride like
c
teaches people
or like or no because then she might
take it out of anger and be like [ __ ]
you for saying that no listen yes i
fully
live my life with that motto yeah and it
fully backs like it [ __ ] backfires on
me all the time like that way feels
great
raised yeah and that's how i've gotten
my 14 year old to hate me so
but like the other if the goal if the
other goal is to finally make this [ __ ]
the bride understands see he [ __ ]
sucks
you know let's not have him around as
much anymore then you you take the more
like softer approach of like oh no
i knew this was going to happen see i
told you
then that will drive like that will make
her more inclined to agree and be like
yeah this kid does [ __ ] suck but it's
not just them for the future situations
and she'll be more inclined to listen
instead of being like oh she's just
being a [ __ ] yeah trying to like rub it
in that's why i'm like yes you're right
like it's crazy that one doesn't feel
better that one feels it's creating more
of an enemy that's not listen right
exactly
um second comment says
everyone here sucks yeah it was a bad
moment to say something like that but
man i wish i was there to see it yeah
they got mad at you for trying to save
the wedding from drama then you're
proven right and now it's suddenly not
okay again bad timing but i love the
pettiness yeah
i just don't imagine the scenario going
any other possible way you know what i
mean like yeah in my head it doesn't go
the way where we're like
well you know he's a great kid and all
but like i we kind of we
try to discuss this beforehand we
thought this could be you know he could
be disruptive at times and so we just
was trying to ask if he could figure out
a way to
keep an eye on him during the wedding a
little bit more than usual blah blah
blah like you're just you know i'm like
who's gonna [ __ ] do that yeah no
one's doing that everyone's [ __ ]
drunk on red wine and then the [ __ ]
[ __ ] can be like i told you so
like that's the only way it's gonna
happen it's not gonna happen this
diplomatic way yeah um
so the sentiment of the whole all the
comments is
look you were the [ __ ] for saying it
like that but this is hilarious but why
is she the [ __ ] i just still don't
get it
um
the kid is out of control and it's past
time that the family needs to do
something about it possibly adding
insult to injury though she brought it
on herself but
you put salt on the wound so yeah you're
an [ __ ] but i think everyone agrees
that
we'll let that one slide
um
this person says
i'm seeing not the [ __ ] um you it's
just that you are a justified [ __ ]
you raised your concerns your
sister-in-law ignored them which is fine
and then she then told you you were
wrong which you weren't but that's fine
she then told her family who sent you
messages like how could you say that
about my child which was really wrong
she shouldn't have done that your
sister-in-law spread your warning to her
family who then message you this
entitles you say [ __ ] you you were wrong
i was right i told you so so yeah every
like everyone agrees everyone's like
and you kind of rubbed it in her face
after she's running away crying already
which is a shitty thing to do but we
understand why you did it she's
hilarious
another top comment says am i the only
one that laughed
and someone else says no because i think
it's
hilarious um
i i wish i would have been able to see
the family members faces after she said
i told you
especially the ones that took the time
to write her a message yeah right well
yeah
god there are some kids like that in my
family it's just like dude
you guys suck like [ __ ] these kids man
they're awful and then they grow up to
be shitty people and it's like yeah i
told you so you know
so but i i
i really wish i was there to see that
and that i told you so feels so good not
a lot of like people don't get a lot of
opportunities where they get that
slam dunk i told you it's like a slam
dunk yeah like she's like don't bring
that kid and then every possible thing
goes wrong
besides the then you catching on fire
right yeah
and these people will never admit that
they're wrong they'll never admit that
you're that's why you gotta kick it yeah
i'm like i told you yeah i told you get
it in when you gotta break it out you
gotta break their [ __ ] like facade
that they have they're still going to
make excuses oh but he it was a mistake
he just tripped and fell without they're
so cool
i've dealt with these parents before
it's like dude
shut up
oh my god shut the [ __ ] up already like
all right thanks for watching this
episode i hope you guys had fun uh we
have a lot of fun doing these having
jess on am i the [ __ ] you guys were
right yeah that was a good idea i know
it's really fun
uh but uh we're probably gonna be doing
more of these in the future if you guys
enjoyed the video make sure you like
subscribe comment check out our uh our
sponsors below you know comment tell us
your opinions on are these people
[ __ ] or not and you know what let us
know like are they that was that person
the [ __ ] for saying i told you so
because i i want to i want we wanna hear
you guys opinions on this too there was
a justified [ __ ] yeah until then it's
me gina jess and tiff we'll see you guys
next week bye love you bye
[Music]
so
[Music]